it was October 13th 2012 a day that I
will never forget I was on my bike
pushing up what seemed like a
never-ending barren hill and it wasn't
just any Hill it was a 15 mile climb up
to town called javi on the Big Island of
Hawaii and it wasn't just any ride it
was at the Ironman World Championship I
can still feel my muscles burning I was
struggling tired and dehydrated as I
could feel the heat emanating from the
asphalt measuring almost 98 degrees I
was near the halfway point of the bike
portion of one of the most prestigious
longest single day endurance race events
in the world every year during my
childhood I watched this very race on TV
in our family living room i sat next to
my dad on our 1970s tile orange and
brown sofa and I remember being an utter
art how these athletes push themselves
to their limit in this grueling race and
just so you don't get the wrong idea my
family members weren't just spectators
they were incredibly athletic and I
always participated from the sidelines
cheering on my three siblings are
handing out water at local races I
remember wanting so badly to be able to
compete but I couldn't even though I
couldn't play sports I decided to be
active in my community I volunteered at
the local hospital in high school in
college I interned at the White House
studied abroad in Spain and backpack
through Europe all by myself with my leg
braces and crutches upon graduating I
moved to New York City for a job in
management consulting earned an MBA got
married and now have a daughter
at age 28 I was introduced to the sport
of hand cycling and then triathlon and
by luck I met Jason Fowler an ironman
world champion at a camp for athletes
with disabilities and like me he
competed in a wheelchair and with his
encouragement at age 34 I decided to go
after Kona the Kona or Hawaii Ironman is
the oldest iron distance race in the
sport and if you're not familiar it's
like the Super Bowl of triathlon and the
Ironman for a wheelchair athlete like me
it consists of 2.4 a mile open water
swim in the Pacific Ocean 112 mile
handcycle ride in lava fields now that
sounds exotic but it's not as scenic as
it sounds and it's pretty desolate and
then you top it off with a marathon or
26.2 mile run in 90-degree heat using a
racing wheelchair that's right it's a
total distance of a hundred and forty
point six miles using just your arms in
less than 17 hours
no female wheelchair athlete had ever
completed the race because of the strict
seemingly impossible cutoff times and so
there I was putting it all out on the
line and when I finally reached the top
of that 15 mile climb I was discouraged
there was no way I was gonna make that
swim by time limit of ten and a half
hours because I was almost two hours off
pace I had to make the agonizing
decision to quit I removed my timing
chip but I handed it over to race
official my day was done my best friend
Shannon and my husband Sean we're
waiting at the top of javi to drive me
back to town and on my way back to town
I began to cry I bailed my dream of
completing the Ironman World
Championship was crushed I was
embarrassed I felt like I'd messed up
I'm worried about what my friends my
family and people had work would think
of me what was I gonna put on Facebook
isn't gonna explain to everyone that
things and go the way I had assumed or
planned a few weeks later I was talking
to Shannon about the conet disaster and
and she said this to me
Minda big dreams and goals can only be
realized when you're ready to fail I
knew I had to put that failure behind me
in order to move forward and it wouldn't
be the first time that I had faced
insurmountable odds I was born in Bombay
India and just before my first birthday
I contracted polio which left me
paralyzed from the hips down unable to
care for me my birth mother left me at
an orphanage fortunately I was adopted
by an American family and I moved to
Spokane Washington just shortly after my
third birthday over the next few years I
underwent a series of surgeries on my
hips my legs and my back that allowed me
to walk with leg braces and crutches as
a child I struggled with my disability I
felt like I didn't fit in people stared
at me all the time I was embarrassed
about wearing a back brace and leg
braces and I always hid my chicken legs
under my pants as a young girl I saw
thick heavy braces on my legs didn't
look pretty or feminine among my
generation I am one of the very few
individuals in the u.s. who are living
with paralysis by polio today many
people who contract polio in developing
countries do not have access to the same
medical care education or opportunities
like I have had in America many do not
even live to reach adulthood I have the
humbling knowledge that had I not been
adopted I most certainly wouldn't be in
front of you today I may not even be
alive all of us in our own lives may
face seemingly insurmountable goals I
want to share with you what I learned
when I tried again one year after my
first attempt on a sunny Saturday
morning my husband Sean don't mean to
the ocean at the Kona pier and with
2,500
closest friends and competitors we
started swimming as that cannon went off
promptly at 7:00 a.m. I focused on one
stroke at a time staying in between
bodies counting my strokes 1 2 3 4 and
lifting my head to sight every so often
just so I wouldn't got too off track and
when I finally reached a shoreline Shawn
picked me up and he carried me out of
the water I was so stunned and thrilled
when Shawn had told me I had managed a 1
hour and 43 minutes with him time on to
the bike segment I had 8 hours and 45
minutes to complete the hundred and
twelve mile bike course I broke up the
course in seven to ten mile segments in
my mind just to reduce the enormity of
the race the first 40 miles they clipped
by as we benefited from a little
tailwind by 4:00 p.m. I made it to mile
94 and I did the math and I realized I
was in serious time jeopardy because I
had 18 miles ago in less than 90 minutes
and and that included a few sizeable
hill climbs I was stressed out and I was
scared that I was gonna make that time
cut off again at this point I pushed my
internal voice aside that said this
hurts quit and I told myself
Binda you better focus focus on what you
can control and that is your attitude in
your effort I resolve to be okay being
uncomfortable and I told myself push
harder forget about the pain and keep
that laser focus for the next 90 minutes
I cranked as though my life depended on
it and when I rolled into town I heard
on the loudspeaker
Minda dead there is one of the last
competitors to make the bike cut off I
did it
by only three minutes
it was 527 p.m. and I have been racing
for 10 and a half hours the first 10
miles of the run went pretty quickly as
I was so excited to finally pass people
with my three wheels to there to fear
the Sun quickly went down and I found
myself pulling up to the bottom of
Palani Hill looking straight into a
half-mile hill that looked like Mount
Everest at Mile 124 of the race my
friends and family were ready at their
stations to talk me up that hill I was
struggling tired that's really gripping
those rooms just so I wouldn't tip
backwards when I finally reached the top
of that hill I turned left onto a very
lonely 15 mile stretch turn to the Queen
K highway totally exhausted I pressed on
focusing on one push at a time by 9:30
p.m. I made that final right-hand turn
onto Lee Drive
I heard the crowds roar and I was
overcome with emotion I crossed that
finish line
[Music]
my final time was 14 hours and 39
minutes for the first time in the
35-year history
a female wheelchair athlete completed
the Ironman World Championship
and it wasn't just any Female Athlete it
was me a paralyzed portion from India
against all odds I achieved my dream and
through this very personal commitment to
myself I slowly realized that completing
the Ironman was about more than
conquering Kona it was about conquering
polio and other disabling but
preventable diseases not only for myself
but for the millions of children who
have been and still will be afflicted by
vaccine preventable diseases today we
are closer than ever to eliminating one
of those diseases everywhere in the
world in the mid-1980s polio once
paralyzed more than 350,000 children a
year in more than 125 countries that
amounted to a staggering 40 cases an
hour by contrast so far this year the
last endemic countries have reported a
total of only 12 cases since 1988 more
than 2.5 billion children have been
immunized against polio and an estimated
16 million children who otherwise would
have been paralyzed like me are walking
despite this incredible progress we know
that until it's eradicated polio remains
a very real threat especially to
children and the poorest communities of
the world it can reimagine some of the
most remote and dangerous places and
from there it can spread and so this is
my new Iron Man to end polio and I am
reminded every day when I look at my two
and a half year old daughter Maya she is
able to climb a ladder in the park
push her scooter or pick a ball across
the grass almost everything that I see
her do at her age reminds me what I
could not do at that age and when she
was 2 months old I took her to get her
first polio vaccine and when the doctor
came in the room two
Perla shot I asked him if I could take a
picture to document the moment when we
left the room I could feel my eyes
welling up with tears I cried the entire
way home it was in that moment that I
realized that my daughter's life would
be very different from mine she will
never be faced with the crippling
disability of polio because a vaccine
was available and I chose to get hurt
immunized she can do anything she wants
as can each of you now I'd like to leave
you all with one question what is your
Ironman thank you
[Music]
[Applause]